he's one of the top golf instructors in
all the land and you can catch not one
not two
but three different pieces of content on
golf pass
thanks to him golf swing coach chris
cuomo here
on the rich eisen show how are you chris
god doing well thanks fresh
doing good okay first things first i i
always ask the most hard-hitting
questions first
okay how many how many people have uh
confused you with chris cuomo
of cnn how many times that happened in
your life
more more like jokes like oh chris come
on cnn um
no one's ever confused me but uh okay
but definitely definitely have gotten
the comments
quite a few times yeah like why why why
would i want the guy
on cnn to helping me with my golf swing
i don't know how many times that's
happened to you but yeah okay
but not too many is what you're saying
pretty much yeah i i've heard versions
of that but never actually suddenly
confused me but i've heard versions of
of um people adjusting with me
for sure how did you get involved in
this end of the business
chris how did that happen yeah i mean
i took up golf late i'm a first
generation golfer a friend of mine
sort of took my golf when i was 16 and
got a job at driving range to sort of
pay for my golf
and pretty early on um just developed
great relationships with a bunch of
coaches
and they were helping with my game but
just developed this like passion for
for just teaching and coaching in
general and when i graduated college
i kind of knew that was what i wanted to
do and just very quickly
just kind of jumped into it traveled
traveled the country worked for a bunch
of different top coaches at their
academies and
and just sort of confirmed my love and
passion for it just kept going with it
um so it's been 23 years or so now that
i've been teaching so it's been a lot of
fun
and when was the first time you got
fixed up with bryce and deshamble
how did that one come about chris uh
we've been friends
for quite a while he's uh you know went
to smu lived in the dallas area i've
been dallas for 15 years
we've just talked golfing quite a bit
over the years and then that
relationship just evolved into where we
started working on things and it became
more and more of a full-time thing and
we've been going you know full-time now
for about two and a half years or so so
just a fun person to kind of try to
figure things out with
uber talented obviously works incredibly
hard
obviously um and just so curious so
it's just a great environment to see you
know what sort of small edges can we
find here and there in the game
so it's it's of all the things you just
said chris cuomo the words
working on things could probably be its
own book
um so the what are the things you're
working on or that you worked on with
bryce and deshambo
chris oh i mean jeez i mean we can go
down some crazy sort of rabbit holes
when it comes to like give me the
craziest rabbit hole you got
like what do you got okay so the biggest
mystery in golf right is like where does
a person
control the golf ball come from why is
it that an
18 handicapper can hit a hole in one on
one shot the next shot the ball goes out
of bounds it's maddening right yes
it's maddening for a professional golfer
also why can someone play really well
one week and miss a cut the next week
so where does that air quotes
repeatability of your golf shots come
from that's sort of like one of the big
questions in golf and golf instruction
and you know bryson
he's obsessed with that obviously he's
like really into gaining distance
so that's been a lot of fun we went down
that rabbit hole but he's also really
into this whole kind of um repeatability
idea
and you know we've come up with a couple
things um
you know one of them is basically he
moves his body in a way where he
you know gets pretty close to kind of
hitting an end range of motion at
certain parts
where he can't like overshoot a spot so
it becomes
less likely that he'll for example close
the face too much
so just kind of little things like that
i mean we could have
probably a two-hour segment just on this
topic but uh
just at the end of the day where does
that sort of idea of consistency come
from
um but then again also he went down this
whole path of creating speed so
every part of the game he he's just
trying to figure out the whole thing
it's pretty wild where does the
controversy come from though i mean what
or do you scratch your head saying why
are people getting so uh uptight about
this whole thing here
you know i mean so where do you stand on
that
chris the distant side of it i don't
know just did the fact that
he he i don't know that that i guess
people think that he's just you know
come up in a laboratory with something
that
uh it kind of you know is a cheat code
in a way noi
that he just does something so
repeatable and he does it in a certain
way that comes up
pisses people off i don't know i don't
know i mean people
kind of people i guess in general love
to find someone to kind of like root
against a bit you know but i mean
bryson's got his supporters too a lot of
people appreciate kind of the uniqueness
yes he comes to the game with um
i mean look he is he trying to find sort
of edges and different ways to think
about the game
that have been thought about before to
help them perform at the highest level
sure
does that sort of um um
you know sort of like go against you
know kind of traditionalist approach
maybe at times um definitely wouldn't
call it a cheat code i mean there's
probably no one who works harder at the
game than he does on the pga tour so
so i don't think anybody can accuse him
of taking a shortcut when it comes to
work ethic
he's trying to work his way into um just
you know possibly approaching it
slightly different and hopefully
becoming you know the best part of the
world by doing so
chris como here on the rich eisen show
last one for you on bryson
um what did you think of uh the sixth
hole at bay hill
a couple weeks ago where he just said
that big large
mass of water screw it i'm just going to
hit it straight over it what'd you think
of that one
that was fun wasn't it i i think i was a
lot i i think it was just
it's one of those things where there's
obviously tremendous risk to it but at
the end of the day there's a lot of
upside
and part of the upside was just sort of
like the entertainment value i mean how
fun was that to watch for him to
actually pull that off
um so this is where you know i think his
approach to the game
is and this is why people are are
watching because it's fundamentally
entertaining he's trying to do things
differently
and we we kind of joke around a lot you
know with some of this new found
distance and some of the ways that we
try to look at things slightly different
it's almost like he's trying to play
golden tea out there right take sort of
like
kind of like the magic secret line that
you wouldn't otherwise you know sort of
see that you had to have like
a special knowledge to sort of take
whatever so you know trying to turn it
into almost like you know a video game
of sorts which again might piss some
people off but
um it's rooted in a really strong work
ethic so i would encourage people to not
be pissed off about it but but
you know appreciate kind of the way he's
going about it so technically what's the
trackball
is it his hips movement or his big ass
biceps or what what
what's the trackball in the golden tee
chris what is that yeah probably his
forearms and
he's he's got some pretty strong arms
and that at the end of the day that's
that's how you're applying force to the
club is through your hands and
your body's you know helping to kind of
amplify that but he's got
he's got great hands great great really
strong forms uh helps them control the
face create a lot of club at speed so i
would say that's the the track blog
okay we're making that analogy the track
ball right here
uh chris chromo chris cuomo here on the
rich eisen show so you're at a golf
galaxy in the great state of texas right
now what what's going on where you are
because i know
that's part of the reason why you want
to come on this show other than have a
great fun conversation
uh what's going on with that chris yeah
they've done a great job i
came in here they just to really see how
they've renovated the store
completely revamped their whole teaching
club fitting program
done a really nice job of hiring some
some lpga pga professionals
to help someone improve their game have
a club fitting staff
obviously you've got a great selection
of actual equipment so i'm really
impressed with what they've done to put
together a nice sort of game improvement
kind of package
under under one roof and you have not
one not two but three as i mentioned
pieces of content on golf pass which we
talk a lot about here on nbc sports on
peacock uh
como concepts swing expedition with
chris cuomo
and my daily routine let me let me ask
you this
question chris when you mention an 18
handicapper
who can hit a hole in one on one swing
and then spray it all over the place
on the next uh i'm on the ladder i've
never done the former
i'm the latter um you know and
i have honestly i have trouble
concentrating i i go out on a golf
course and i just love the
the atmosphere i love the trees i love
the you know the
how beautiful everything is i'm just not
that guy who stands over the golf ball
and goes through the same damn routine
what piece of advice would you have for
a hacker who just has trouble
just flat out concentrating just loves
going out there and hitting the
that little white ball around yeah i
mean it depends right you just said you
love it so
for you for you i would i wouldn't say
do anything different you love it right
at the end of the day the game's
recreation for you so if you love just
kind of like sort of spacing out looking
at the trees and the animals i mean
that's
a really worthy way to spend like your
day like if you enjoy it so i wouldn't
say do anything else now here to tell me
i hate that i do that i want to learn
how to focus better i mean you know
there's
there's mental coaches i did a thing
with a group called neuropeak last week
where they do brainwave training so
there's all sorts of things you can do
to help
i need brainwave training i didn't say
you need it
i think you should stay like stay with
what you're doing but you're having fun
i i am having fun but i'd like to i'd
you know i'd like to get down to the
single digit you know i mean
i i i it just i i i i have trouble with
the repeatable swing
i don't have i don't have the traps like
bryce and deshambo
uh i hit the traps unfortunately you
gotta find a good coach maybe it's some
swing stuff
i don't know you make the assumption
that it's it's you enjoying your
environment i don't know if i'd make
that assumption i think you can enjoy
your environment and maybe work on your
game a little bit
okay so then i guess is there is there
a piece of advice that is
um translatable for every type of player
there is
to improve is there is there a magic
bullet of one
particular piece of advice whether it is
a setup whether it is a suggestion
to have a routine or something like that
what what might it be chris
cuomo it doesn't exist there is no one
magic bullet
you just got you got to find a person to
partner with the coach
and kind of go down that path if there
is
i mean you know this game is tough right
anybody's played a game this is like
super
super challenging um but um
you just got to find the right group to
to to partner with the right team to
partner with
what are you doing saturday
oh wow what a flex that
no no no no is i mean chris if you don't
want to do it
you could just say i don't want to do it
you don't just say i'm sorry i gotta be
in augusta
right i mean so so see you're there
you're there
sorry no it's okay i remember bryson and
jason
you know yeah i mean that that works
that works
so what is it like what's a week like
for you at augusta
chris uh do that for me week like at
augusta
you know flying on saturday got to get
coveted tested probably not do much on
saturday
and then just sunday just kind of
typical just check out the course
work on the game with people uh just
sort of divide the game plan given what
the the course is
is allowing for that week and then and
then just just go
you know the the whistle goes on uh the
horn goes on thursday so just kind of go
and see what happens and i'll be there
for the players i coach in case um we
got to troubleshoot anything along the
way but um
hopefully not hopefully it's fairly
smooth sailing and
and people get into the middle of it and
compete and
you know we'll see what happens sunday
evening so who do you have in
in the field this this time bryson and
jason
all right so that's why you don't have
time for me i get it chris no worries
we'll just have to
can you wait a week yeah sure why not i
told you
i have trouble focusing so you know
i'll just space out for another week no
problem hey chris thanks for the call
appreciate it everyone should check out
chris
um on golf pass with three shows
como concepts swing expedition with
chris como
and my deal coming out next week
actually specializes on distance and
we've got kyle berkshire bryce and
duchamp and a bunch of other
sort of like distance experts who are
going to be on that one
okay and i would also also see for you
know again i was so impressed with what
golf galaxy's done so
check out golfgalaxy.com um they're
doing a really good job with putting
together a bunch of
of people to help um that whole game
improvement process
safe travels to augusta chris como and
let's chat on the other side of it
thank you so much you guys that's chris
cuomo here on the rich eisen show
the valero open the valero texas open
this is why i guess
he's going to augusta he's got jason day
and bryson deshambo
at the uh masters next week the valero
texas open
right before it check it out on nbc
saturday
at 3 30 p.m eastern time
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here